how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel
everything relating to the mcu and the
s-p-u-m-c
or the sony pictures universe of marvel
characters and we have some breaking
news concerning both of those
universes today we have some news about
spider-man 3
and venom 2 as sony has officially
commented on the release of
both of these films and it's about time
because everybody's really been
wondering what's up with venom 2
we haven't gotten an official teaser
trailer for it yet and nobody really
knows when it's going to come out and as
far as spider-man 3 is concerned we just
heard
yesterday that the production of the
film is pushed back to 2021 so an
official response from
sony is really good timing so we'll
break it all down in this video and talk
about what it means
for the future but first if you're new
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest marvel news
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a gladiator
hulk funko pop
so at bank of america's 2020 media
communications and entertainment
conference
sony pictures entertainment chairman
tony vincy kiera
commented on what they plan to do with
some of their specific
films releasing in 2020 2021
and beyond and really what it comes down
to is the pandemic and this is what he
had to say
what we won't do is make the mistake of
putting a very
very expensive 200 million dollar movie
out in the market unless we're sure that
the theaters are open and
operating at a significant capacity he
went on to say
you'll see a lot of strange things
happen over the next six months
in how films are released how they're
scheduled how they're marketed
but once we get back to normal we will
have learned a lot i think and found
ways to do
things that are somewhat different and
hopefully better
now what this means is that they're not
going to release
big films that cost them a lot of money
during the pandemic
as long as theaters aren't open at
pretty much full capacity they're not
going to release venom 2
or spider-man 3. and we've already kind
of seen that mindset they've pushed
venom 2 back already
they pushed the release date of
spider-man 3 back and just
recently again they delayed the
production of the film until 2021
and unfortunately this seems to be the
take of most major studios as black
widow we found out
will most likely be delayed as well and
this primarily has to do with tinnette
only doing about 20 million domestically
in the opening weekend
tennant was built up to be and was
supposed to be one of the biggest movies
of all time and it most likely still
will be but obviously 20 million
domestically over the weekend
opening weekend isn't nothing to brag
about it may be in the circumstances
given the pandemic
but if things were normal this number is
not that significant and essentially
that's what sony is saying they're not
going to release these super high budget
films to only make
a little bit of their money back so
unfortunately as long as this pandemic
is going and all the theaters aren't
opened back up sony is not going to
release venom 2
or spider-man 3. the pandemic is not
likely going away anytime
soon but hopefully it can get somewhat
in control over the next let's say half
a year
and hopefully we can get venom 2 and
spider-man 3
in 2021 and not have to wait until 2022.
unfortunately the situation is what it
is but let me know what you think in the
comments down below
don't forget to subscribe to stay up to
date on all of the latest news so you're
in the know about everything
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you